you gotta ask yourself what are you
fighting for Adonis Creed has been
challenged by Victor Drago son of the
man who killed his father I'm taking the
fight let's just say anything your
father said he died right here in my
hands
this kid was raised in hate dangerous
this won't be the end to me
or you
because we're a team
Creed to rated pg-13
we don't do who he'd love then he
wouldn't exist I'm good it's like
nothing really matters to him right now
including me you gotta think real hard
about this do you have people that need
you no I'm taking the fight
Victor Drago son of Ivan Drago who
infamously killed Apollo Creed appeared
today to issue a challenge to Adonis
Creed don't do this ain't got a choice
that's the same thing your father said
you died right here in my hands
that kid was raised in Haiti dangerous
he broke things to me that I never been
fixed ain't worth it
is not just us anymore day I want to
rewrite history if you will to fight
this man that's your business
but don't pretend this is about your
father
this here is all about my kids
tonight of his head it was
[Music]
the tribulation
this won't be the end to me
are you
they can't because we're a team
[Music]
now you know what you're fighting for
Wow after brown you learn more about
yourself when I stepped in Henry it
wasn't all about me
you
[Music]
you